well thanks to dedicated shelter workers  a 15 year old dog is reunited with his  extended family  his owner passed away while visiting las  vegas so he ended up at the animal  foundation  well after lots of calls and  coordination the elderly dog  joined his owner's family come here big  man  now katya hadn't seen huxley in a few  months but the terrier mix recognized  her right away  huxley and her brother seth were  inseparable  so when she got the call she drove from  near buffalo new york  to pick him up in las vegas james  phillips became attached to huxley and  gave the senior  special care an extremely friendly dog  of course a little bit older so a little  bit slower moving his responses aren't  very quick  [Music]  but extremely friendly very easy going  very mellow dog  this is why i took him into my home  the family is safe in new york tonight  and are very grateful to have their  brother and son's beloved friend back  home because they know  seth would have wanted that